here we are on lecture three
uh you remember last time we were
discussing the complexity of this
problem
uh minimizing over all polynomials p
this one norm is bounded by t
of the absolute value the expectation
x and f is a fixed function
and i claimed that um
this optimization problem can be
approximately solved using
um
a projected version of gradient descent
this could be done so this can be solved
in time polynomial and n and one over
epsilon and t
epsilon here is your error parameter
and this allows you to agnostically
learn sparse polynomials
what i wanted to do today so this result
is somewhat involved
and i wanted to describe at a fairly
high level
how to solve this problem
using boosting
and i wanted to emphasize
you'll see when we get to agnostic
boosting because we're working in the
agnostic model
that there are some really nice
advantages to doing boosting combining
boosting with the agnostic model it's
another
reason why i sort of um really like the
agnostic model of learning
okay so let me remind you
what is boosting
so again imagine you have access
the learner has access to f
and there's no noise let's think about
the noiseless case
and let's you know the goal of course is
to output
h such that the probability that h
does not equal f is at most epsilon
instead i'm going to describe the weak
learning
assumption
and i'm going to assume that the learner
that we only have a learner
that can output a hypothesis
that is say um 51
accurate so your gamma would be
1 um
you know this being able to come up with
an epsilon accurate hypothesis this is
often referred to as strong learning
and if you're only able to come up with
a hypothesis that has accuracy 51
we call this weak learning
and a major result of rob shapiri
was that
if
there exists a weak learner
that succeeds with respect to
all distributions
d this implies
that there exists a strong
learner
that succeeds
with respect to all distributions
okay so remember here we were sort of
interested in learning just with respect
to the uniform distribution
okay and what i'm claiming boosting
uh will accomplish uh is that it will
take a weak learner
but the leak the weak learner has to
succeed with respect to all
distributions
um and then if you have a weak learner
that can succeed with respect to all
distributions you'll get a strong
learner
that succeeds with respect to all
distribution so already there's sort of
a
disconnect between what we want to do
that is learn with respect to one kind
of fixed distribution
and here i'm claiming boosting works
with respect to all distributions but
we'll
we'll address that point in a moment and
we'll work around it here
so this reduction is called a boosting
algorithm
so boosting algorithm is
this reduction
and very roughly at a very very high
level what will happen
is the boosting algorithm will run the
weak learner
it will receive a hypothesis that's
correct
say these examples it'll draw a bunch of
examples it'll have a hypothesis that's
correct here and it's incorrect here
the boosting algorithm will create a new
distribution that puts more weight
on these points
and less weight on these points
it'll run the weak learning algorithm
again to obtain another hypothesis
it will um then modify the distribution
again
and so on and so forth and then at the
end it will take a majority of
these weak hypotheses in order to obtain
a strong hypothesis
so let me show you let me actually give
you an example of a boosting algorithm
that you probably haven't seen
and prove to you that it works it has
some interesting
properties this is called
so let me show you something called
boosting by branching programs
this is by phil long and rocko's for
video
and the reason why i'm going to show you
this boosting algorithm is one you
probably haven't seen it before
and two it's conceptually very simple
and it actually has a
fairly simple proof okay
so remember so uh we're going to assume
that so okay so let's
fix a concept class c
and some c in that concept that you're
trying to learn
again there's no noise here and then
we'll assume that there exists
a weak learner such that
for every distribution
given random examples
x c of x
this is chosen according to d
the weak learner outputs
h such that
the probability of x now i'm going to
i'm going to make a slightly stronger
weak learning assumption
i'm going to assume that all examples
drawn
from the positive part of d
we have h of x equals c of x
at least one half plus gamma and
for all of the examples drawn from the
negative part of d
so d plus is the set of all positively
labeled random examples d minus is the
set of all randomly labeled examples
so you can see i i mean a priori it's
it looks like i'm making a stronger
assumption on the weak learner i mean
you could imagine a distribution that
has very few negative examples
and a successful weak learner that gets
nothing right on d minus
and but it's very successful on d plus
here so here it looks like i'm assuming
something stronger but in fact this
turns out to be equivalent
to the original just the standard plain
weak learning assumption
and this equivalence is an exercise it's
not difficult
by answering yes without looking at the
input with some
probability uh yeah something like that
yes
okay so the algorithm maybe i'll draw it
over here
the first thing the out the boosting
algorithm is going to do is draw a
branching program
well i guess strictly speaking it's just
drawing a graph at this point
and it's going to do this
for t levels capital t
okay this isn't very exciting so i guess
we'll get down here to t levels
and then at the leaves it'll place minus
one
minus one minus one minus one until we
get to
index t over two then it'll start
placing plus ones
plus ones plus one plus
okay um
so the boosting algorithm
does works as follows first it runs the
weak learner
to obtain
h0 and it places h0
at the root of this branching program
then it's going to
a draw large
set of new labeled examples
and um for each one of these new labeled
examples
so some of these so h0 on some of these
new examples h0 may label them
minus
and on some of these new randomly
labeled examples h0
may say plus
so
the randomly chosen examples that h0
labels
minus will induce a new distribution on
examples
okay you randomly choose some examples
and you move to the left
if h0 labels you minus one you
also you know from these randomly chosen
examples
some of them will move to the right if
h0 says plus one so this will correspond
to two
so now we've induced
two new distributions
so is it the one distribution is just
the original distribution
condition on h0 entering plus correct
yep good so d01 is
original distribution conditioned
on h0 equaling zero
and this is original distribution
h1 saying plus
okay what does the indexing mean
right so um at so the index
um
of the ith vertex
at level t
is i so i really mean
you know you go down to level a little t
this has index zero
this says index one this says index two
this is index three
okay so that should have been d zero
zero
oh thanks
sorry one of the instances so this this
should this should be d0 is the original
distribution
this should be d one zero and this
should be d one oh the first one
is the first one measures what level of
uh what level you're in
the second bit is uh where you are
inside that level
yes yeah yes
so we'll induce two new distributions
and we'll run
the weak learner two more times
to get h one zero
and h one one
okay i mean you know the weak learner
works with respect to every distribution
in particular it will work with this
conditional distribution and this
conditional distribution
okay and then i'm going to continue so
here i will have
distribution d20 distribution d21
distribution d22
so i'll i'll draw a new sequence of
examples
i'll look at all of the examples that
end up here
that's some new distribution d20
then i'll you know of of
you know so i'm drawing a sufficiently
large sample of examples
whatever examples appear here this
corresponds to some new distribution on
examples
maybe a bizarre distribution but some
distribution this is also some
distribution on examples
okay so i can run the weak learner again
i'll get h20 h21
h22
and i'll just continue to do this okay
if i'm at
some node in my branching program and
i've taken a sufficiently large sequence
of examples
and none of them reach this node then
i'll just
ignore it i'll chop it off from the
branching program it's
it's not going to be relevant
and looking ahead i'm going to choose t
to be order
log one over epsilon over gamma squared
okay so you have delta uh what is
electron and what is gamma
oh sorry no i have gamma ah this is
gunman
and epsilon is going to be your final
accurate final accuracy
okay so this is the out so this is
really the output
hypothesis this is your combined strong
learner
if you have a new example and you want
to know how to classify this new example
you just take the path in the branching
program according to all of the
hypotheses labeled at each
interior vertex and if you end up on the
right hand side here you say plus one
if you end up on the left hand side you
say minus one
okay so let's pick
a random x
from the positive part of the
distribution
and let's let y sub t
e the index
at level t
that x where x
ends up
okay so x is a random draw from the
positive part of the distribution
and y sub t is a random variable
corresponding to the index at level t
where x ends up and i want to say that
it's clear
that the expectation of y sub capital t
is exactly
t over 2 plus gamma t
is just by linearity of expectation
you could set up an indicator random
variable that
at level i is 1 if you move to the right
and 0 if you move to the left and by the
weak learning hypothesis
you know for a random draw from d plus
the probability when you just locally
look at any one of these nodes in the
branching program that you move to the
right
and your positive is one half plus gamma
because that's the correct direction
and similarly if you know if
x is a negative example
then the expectation of yt is t over 2
minus gamma t okay so in
intuitively this branching program
when you pick a new random x this
example is going to do a biased random
walk inside your branching program
uh and hopefully you know sort of the
bias pushes you towards one side if
you're positive and negative towards the
other side if you're negative
okay yeah simple but remember
we wanted to say that uh
you know so if h
we want the probability when x is drawn
from d
plus that h of x
says plus one we want this to be at
least one minus epsilon
okay so we want um
we want a statement we want to say with
high probability
this branching program is going to
correctly label x from d plus
okay and the problem here
the reason why you can't use kind of a
standard say churn off bound
is that um you know the event that h21
pushes you in the right direction why
should that be independent from the
event that h11 pushed you in the right
direction
or the wrong direction i mean these
these may not be independent events
these
his may be very correlated you know
yeah but the probability of going to the
right condition on having arrived at
this vertex
is still one half plus gamma right
correct because we set it up that we
learn exactly
because we speak to that conditional
yeah but that doesn't mean that
that doesn't mean that it's independent
it doesn't mean that it's independent so
moving towards this high probability
statement is not immediately clear
uh so so what can we do here
welcome group yeah it's a martingale
right
so um
expectation of y t
if if this is your index at level little
t
given y t minus 1
is equal to y t minus 1
plus 1 half plus gamma
if i create this new random variable zt
which equals yt minus
some offset
you can calculate that the expectation
of zt given zt minus one
is exactly zt minus one
and furthermore since you're only moving
uh at most one to the right or one to
the left
at every level of the branching program
you have that zt minus
zt minus one is at most one
now strictly speaking what we want to do
now if you haven't seen this before is
apply
zuma's inequality
and we'd like to say that the
probability that zt
i guess this is a positive example so
the probability that this is less than
t over two
epsilon you need some
you need some margin right like t over
two minus
some yeah but i've already i've already
like subtracted off my
an offset here
yeah so now you know you want you want
this to be less than this is zero or
something like that
i mean i'm subtracting off this
particular offset uh
yeah so you want you want to estimate
the problem
that's greater than t
times gamma yeah yeah you're right
you're right
right because only if only if it's in
expectation you're t over two
uh your t over two plus gamma t minus
gum so
the only way that things go wrong is
that if you're
um if you end if if you end up deviating
by more than gamma t from
from your expectation that's the only
way things go now
strictly speaking if you want to apply a
zuma's inequality i should have
conditioned on zt the entire history
so on and so forth uh but
because we're in a situation
where yt is actually the sum
of zero one indicator random variables
from this branching program uh you you
know
it's sort of well known that i really in
this particular case only need a
condition on z t minus
one okay so there's some
uh slightly delicate issue about when
you know can i apply a zoom as
inequality
i mean strictly speaking typically you
need to condition on the whole history
but
in this particular case because i'm
looking at a sum of zero one indicator
random variables it's it's actually
uh everything is okay
and um daniel do you want to say
something no no
uh so um
uh so we've chosen capital t
precisely to be large enough so that
when you plug it into a zuma's
inequality
uh this is exactly the bound that comes
out
yeah i'm slightly confused so i
understand that for example d one zero
is the probability
it's the distribution condition on the
first test fire moving left
so what is d21 is it kind of conditioned
on
first moving left and right or first
moving right yeah it's
complicated to say in words i mean it's
really
it's just conviction on arriving at this
vertex it's conditioned on arriving at
this vertex yeah
there's no kind of simple way to say it
and it gets even worse as you have
larger depth yeah okay but i think
conceptually this is a simple
it's simple to see what's going on here
and the proof really is
just using a martingale as long as you
just care about constant gammas you
could have done it with a
real tree i guess yeah exactly if if you
wanted to build the
an entire binary tree and gamma's a
constant you would be okay with the
then it would be a strict desuma right
because each path is unique
uh but we definitely want to think of
gamma as being sub-constant
so that's typical yeah i mean we want it
to be
possibly inversely polynomial small
okay so this was sort of an aside
into boosting and now i want to talk
about
agnostic boosting
um so you might recall that you know
again we're interested in this
minimization problem
and uh we said yesterday and i maybe
even mentioned the deep no i we
said yesterday that the sparse algorithm
the km sparse algorithm that we
described on day one actually we'll
uh we'll output a hypothesis
with error something like eight times
opt
plus epsilon you have to you know the
whole point here is you have to you have
to work much harder that's what we're
doing to get rid of this eight
but in some sense you might interpret
this result as
a weak agnostic learning algorithm um
it is getting you some factor times opt
and so
why not apply some boosting type
algorithm to get rid of this
eight okay so
that's sort of that's sort of precisely
what we're what i'm going to claim you
can do
there were two kind of concurrent
results one by
kalai and kannaday
and one by vitaly feldman
that give
kind of agnostic boosting
algorithms
and can be used to take this as your
weak learner use it as a black box
and obtain a strong agnostic learner one
that gets exactly one times opt
plus epsilon and i'm going to describe
sort of the key idea in these boosting
algorithms that lets
us succeed but first i need to describe
the
new weak learning assumption
so it's an agnostic
weak learning assumption
so i'm going to fix again a concept
class c
let's say no sorry i'm going to
um fix a distribution d
again a joint distribution
and then we'll fix a concept class c
and we'll define the correlation of c
with respect to d to be the
max over all c
and c of the expectation
when x y is drawn from d
of c of x times y
okay so this is the
correlation of the most correlated
concept from c i mean it may be very low
depending on what d
is but i'm just going to refer to it as
this
quantity contrast this with the opt
quantity that corresponded to error this
one's corresponding to correlation
and the weak agnostic learning
assumption
for c with respect to d
is that we can output
a hypothesis given random examples from
d
with correlation to the core hypothesis
h
with correlation equal to gamma
times core of cd
minus epsilon zero so i guess i should
sorry the
um the gamma
epsilon zero weak agnostic learning
assumption
is that we can output a hypothesis h
where its correlation
is a factor of gamma times the optimal
minus some additive
epsilon zero
okay so you can start to see how this km
algorithm might fit into this framework
and then theorem again this is
kalai kanade
feldman
is that the weak
agnostic learning is a gamma
epsilon weak agnostic learner
can be converted
into an algorithm that outputs
h such that
probability x
y is chosen from d that h of x
does not equal y is at most opt
plus epsilon zero over gamma
plus epsilon and it runs in time
poly and one over epsilon
okay so given the weak learning
assumption
of this nature assuming that you can
the weak learner is able to make epsilon
zero smaller than gamma
you can really get a very strong
hypothesis that works
optimus epsilon zero over gamma plus
epsilon
and at this point you might say well why
aren't we done we'll take this
weak agnostic learner we'll apply this
theorem
and uh you know we're done we're in
great shape
the reason why we're not done is that if
you recall from the previous boosting
algorithm
how do boosting algorithms work they're
changing
the distribution that you start from by
a little bit
and then they're running the weak
learning algorithm remember the original
we had this weak learning assumption
that you could weekly learn with respect
to all distributions
we needed a weak letter that worked with
respect to all distributions
and we have this km algorithm and it
works
but only with respect to the uniform
distribution
okay so as soon as my boosting procedure
begins to change the distribution
i'm shocked i'm in big trouble
and the remarkable property
so the remarkable property
of these algorithms
is that they do
not change the underlying distribution
okay so you get a a pretty amazing
consequence that is
if you have an agnostic weak learner
with respect to one distribution
i can boost its accuracy with respect to
that same distribution i
don't need to change the distribution
so let's see if you guys can figure out
what the trick is
so just at a very high level remember
you run the week learner you get a
hypothesis
it's correct here it's incorrect here
and the new distribution was formed
remember we want
we want the weak learner we want to come
up with a distribution where the weak
learner is forced to do better on this
part of the examples and so we increase
their weight
and we decrease the weight of these
examples and that forces the weak
learner to do better on this part
now we're in the agnostic setting that's
sort of a hint
um what can the boosting algorithm do
how can it
change this set of examples that we've
chosen without changing
the weight on any of the examples and
still run the weak learner and force it
to do
better on this part where we were
incorrect
yeah on these points that we got correct
we flip
coins so you know
we're going to flip a coin for its label
we're going to change the labels by
flipping coins
now since i've flipped coins on a bunch
of these examples that i previously had
gotten correct
it's completely random on this part of
the distribution
so there's no accurate hypothesis on
this part of the distribution i mean
nothing can do well here it's random
so that's going to for when i run the
weak learner that's going to force it
in order to give its guarantee
of you know what it has it's going to
force it to do better on this
part of the distribution yeah
kind of uh on a high level um
if we are not in the agnostic setting
but
without any errors right without any
incorrect labels
um is it kind of clear that you
cannot do this you kind of kind of boost
with respect to one distribution
yeah yeah i i i mean
well i mean as soon as you change even a
single label
the weak learner may fail this algorithm
this particular idea might fail right oh
no i'm saying as soon as you
okay well if you don't change so now we
can't change labels and i can't change
distributions then i'm just going the
weak learner can just output the same
hypothesis every time
i keep calling it it gives me the same
hypothesis yeah
so what what can you do so this
technique is called random
random relabeling
and it's not quite this simple i mean
you need to be a little careful
you need to probabilistically decide
whether or not to
give a coin flip to your new examples
and
you know the probability that you do
make an example give an example a noisy
label
is dependent upon how many previous
hypotheses that your weak learner has
given have given it correctly so if it's
if most of your hypotheses during this
procedure are doing well in this example
then with high probability you're going
to flip a coin you're
going to make it noisy but there's i
mean there are definitely some
calculations to work out
so it's not it's not simple but it's not
it's not too difficult either
and it works so
once you have a boosting algorithm this
sort of
this type of agnostic boosting algorithm
uh
you really can combine it with
these types of algorithms it really
makes use of the fact that
you can learn even if the correlation is
really small or
quite small yes yes so
um so for example like ngati was saying
earlier he was saying well this this
weak learning assumption that you can
succeed with respect to all
distributions
it's actually very very strong and i was
saying yeah that's the
that's the importance of that's why you
know we should consider
agnostic algorithms because if you can
come up with an algorithm and it
succeeds in the agnostic scenario you
get this very powerful boosting for free
you don't need to succeed with
respect to all distributions now you
could say oh well coming up with an
agnostic learning algorithm is very hard
i would say yes but notice these
algorithms from even 20 years ago happen
to have
some reasonable agnostic properties so
we should really be shooting for that
um okay so you really can combine this
tool
with the km algorithm as a black box and
you will get
opt epsilon
okay so
so that ends um
kind of a unit on learning with the sort
of the unit on learning of noise that i
wanted to talk about
i will talk about random classification
noise
probably tomorrow but more in the
context of hardness results and
reduction
and what i want to talk about now
i want to move on to learning
geometric concepts
okay so at the beginning of this mini
course we talked about learning decision
trees
uh in part because that's what a lot of
people in data mining do they try and
find a decision tree that
is consistent or reasonably consistent
with a data set
another common thing that applied
machine learning people or
data mining people do is they'll
take a sequence of random examples
they'll view these
labeled examples as points in rn
and they'll see if they can find a
hyperplane that puts most of the
positive points on one side
and most of the negative points on
another side and then if you
need to classify a new point that's
randomly chosen
you just see which side of the
hyperplane it's on if it's on this side
you'll label it negative
it's on this side you'll label it
positive and
if you've ever heard of a support vector
machine which is a commonly used tool in
machine learning
inside of that algorithm at the core of
a support vector machine
is an algorithm for finding a hyper
plane that
tries to get as many uh classify as many
points
as possible correct so it's a very kind
of simple primitive
but it's been souped up and used in very
complicated ways
and it's been very useful
so naturally we're going to be
interested in
what is the computational complexity of
finding a good linear
separator
so we're going to be interested in
functions that are the sign
of w dot x minus theta where
typically we'll treat the norm of w as
one although we don't have to
this is called the threshold
the set of points that make this
function positive
are a half space and this f is usually
referred to as a linear threshold
function
so um
right so let's say that w and theta are
unknown
and you're given a sequence of labeled
examples
and you'd like to learn the unknown w's
and thetas
how do you do it much like the case with
learning a parity
each one of these examples corresponds
to
a linear inequality
and so on and so forth and then i can
run
an lp solver
find the unknown wis
this is a polynomial there's a
polynomial time algorithm for solving a
linear program
so in polynomial time i will find a set
of w i's that's consistent with all of
my data
and as i said on day one if you take a
sufficiently large set of examples and
you find a consistent hypothesis
then you will have learned the concept
okay so it's
not too difficult
i should say this is you know somewhat
surprisingly this wasn't written down
until 89 this is blummer
aaron fight housler and warmuth
uh but this problem of learning a half
space has been studied in the 50s by
block
novokov and rosenblatt um
regarding you know they came up with
something called the perceptron
algorithm maybe we'll get to that um
okay so this is great for every
distribution we're able to learn a
linear threshold function
of course uh the question that i'm
interested in
or well i mean the question that for
example that predates this problem in a
way
that vacnic asked that sort of predates
the pac model is
if you're given points that you know
this is the agnostic problem
they're not necessarily consistent with
any one particular hyperplane but you'd
still like to output
a hyperplane that approximately
minimizes the number of mistakes
or is the best fitting hyperplane
what is the complexity
so given arbitrarily labeled points
what's the complexity of finding the
best fitting hyperplane
unfortunately this is a very hard
problem
so for example
if your set of examples
is even with the promise that it's
consistent
or it's 99 consistent with
a hyper half space
np hard
output a half space
that is 51 percent consistent
and this is a result of
guru swami and raghavendra and also
feldman gopalan
kot and panaswamy
okay so it's quite a difficult problem
and this is also true if the domain is
rn or if it's
minus 1 1 to the n for both of these
cases
you get np hardness and then you might
say well
okay i don't care if you output
an actual hyperplane i'm okay if you
output something odd
some weird geometric concept or even a
circuit that encodes some weird
geometric concept
as long as the error of this hypothesis
that you output is competitive with the
best fitting hyperplane
and this problem is cryptographically
hard
this is work with
sasha sherstoff it's
um you could break lattice-based
cryptosystems
if you were able to solve this
particular problem
so it's sort of surprisingly hard sort
of
bad news
but you know these methods
seem to work very well we might wonder
why
or exactly how perverse are these
distributions that figure into the
hardness results
so i think a natural thing to do
is to consider the case or consider
cases as we have been doing
when the marginal distribution on d of x
is say uniform
on minus 1 1 to the n or gaussian
so these are you know two extremely
commonly well studied distributions
what can we say so in this what can we
say if i know
something about some structure on the
position of the points
and what i want to show you is that in
both cases
we can agnostically learn
in time n to the big o of one over
epsilon squared
by the way what if what if it's not
arbitrary what if it's just random noise
ah so random classification noise i
don't know the
term so each label is flipped
independently with some probability then
you can solve the problem
yeah um
hopefully maybe tomorrow we'll talk more
about that but uh any algorithm
so there's a has to do with statistical
queries
any algorithm that can be learned via
statistical queries which is a
type of access to the random examples is
automatically noise tolerant in that
sense and
this is true for this class
okay so
not surprisingly uh
what i want to do and what we've shown
that you can you know what suffices for
agnostic learning
well the existence of low-degree
polynomial approximators
okay that's what we've talked about over
the last couple of days and that's
really the only tool that we have
so i guess i should say that the output
so the goal here will be to find
a polynomial p
of degree order one over epsilon squared
such that the expectation of
p minus sine w dot x minus theta
squared is at most epsilon and then
we'll
output the sine of p
as we've talked about you know just keep
in the back of your mind
as long as you have a polynomial
approximator you can do agnostic
learning and time
exponential and degree and so this is
really
what we're interested in so let's take
d of x to be gaussian
an rn
so we have the univariate
gaussian the pdf of the univariate
gaussian
and then we'll have the n-variate
gaussian
and so i can rewrite remember we want to
p
that you know has small expectation i
can rewrite this expectation
as the integral over rn
of p minus the sine w dot x minus theta
squared 5x
dx
okay now because we're working with the
gaussian and everything is symmetric
without loss of generality i ca and i'm
not going to use any properties of the
coordinate system here
i can assume that the optimal half space
is just the sine of x1
okay so i can assume that w equals one
zero zero zero
oh right so for simplicity let's set
theta to be zero
okay just to make life simple you can
deal with it
deal with it later now since we've
rotated everything so that w
is one zero zero zero we're left with
just
x one sine of x one sitting here
so i can really simplify this integral
so now it's a sort of a classical
question
exactly
excuse me
all right now now it's as you say now
it's a classical problem
on real approximation theory on the line
and
you know since you're working in l2
with the square here and you're
considering the line and the gaussian
measure
yeah the obvious thing you want to do is
to consider
an orthogonal family
of polynomials
on the line with respect to the gaussian
and these are called the hermit
polynomials
they're very very well studied in
classical approximation theory
and they're a sequence of univariate
polynomials
i forget what h x 2 and x 3 are h 3
x x i think it's x squared yeah i think
it's minus two or root two or something
like that
um and they have the nice property
that well they're orthogonal
so h i h j 5
x dx equals 0 if i does not equal j
and h i squared
equals 1.
and the other reason why i'm bringing up
the hair meat polynomials
is that later we're going to talk about
learning general convex sets
um
and so we're not going to be able to
simplify
all of these learning problems in rn
down to the line
i mean we got lucky that we can do that
because we were looking with we're
trying to approximate just one half
space
but in general when we're looking at
more complicated objects we won't be
able to sort of project down onto the
line
and so it's good to know you know this
whole time we've been talking about
functions that map minus 1 1 to the n
to minus 1 1 and we've had these parity
functions
these were our basis functions
and we said that every f can be written
as
a linear combination
of these parity functions um
and these f-hat s's were the 48
coefficients now we're looking at
functions from rn let's say from -1 1 to
1.
and the distribution is gaussian
and we'll only consider functions that
are bounded
in this sense
so their square with respect to the
gaussian measure is
bounded then it turns out that you can
write
f
or i should say you can write f
as a linear combination
of products
of hair meat polynomials
so um so for every
i guess for every tuple
um of natural numbers
you'll get some product of hair meat
polynomial so for example
you know 1 2 1 3
would be h1 of
x 1 h2 of
x 2 squared h
3 of x 3
4 of x
cubed
and so on and so forth so i can take
products of hair meat polynomials
and these will be your new basis
functions whereas
when we were looking at fourier analysis
on over the hypercube
your basis functions
were parities just x1 x2
x3 or x7 wait why do you need the square
and
i had a 2 here yeah so it's h2 is it's
for the two
and and then you put h right you have
h0 h you know oh yeah yeah yeah
sorry it's yeah yeah you're right
sorry yeah all right thank you
yeah thanks
right so every so you know the analogy
i'm just trying to make is that
you know over the hypercube you can
write every function as some linear
combination of these monomials
with respect to the gaussian measure and
rn you can write every function that's
bounded this way
as some infinite linear combination of
products of hair meat polynomials
in particular anytime you have a family
of orthogonal polynomials on the line
with respect to some distribution
you can take products and you can work
in a higher dimensional space
but let's finish this particular problem
um so what are we trying to do
we're trying to approximate p and the
sine of x one
so f think of f now
so f corresponds to sine of x
and since we know that every f can be
written as a linear combination
we're again on the line here as of of
hermite polynomials that means that f
can be written as the sum from i
equals zero to infinity of c i
h i of x
and we know that this is i mean it's
equal to this and in fact we know that
the best
degree d approximate we still have plant
trails equation
so the best degree d approximation to f
so best degree d
approximation
is
the sum of the first d
and we even have a formula for ci ci
is exactly the fourier transform so it's
sine of x times h i of x
times e to the minus x squared over 2.
i'm omitting the constant dx
and the error of
so let's call this polynomial q
the error of q
is the sum of the squares
of the coefficients that we didn't take
just like in the fourier polynomial over
the cube
if you take all the degree d
coefficients your error is the sum of
the squares of the coefficients you
didn't take
and this
so uh you know
this isn't is looking pretty nice now i
mean
we need to compute the sum of the
squares of these ci's
but all we have here is a sine so i can
break up this integral into minus
infinity
to zero the sine will be minus one plus
zero to infinity the sine will be one
and then i'm left with
h i of x times the gaussian measure dx
but you know these h i of x's are
concocted to
work extremely well and behave very
nicely with respect to the gaussian
measure so
you know if you uh you know there are
books on here meat polynomials you can
certainly find a formula for this type
of integral and get a bound and that's
sort of what we did
and you can prove that this quantity
is order of one over root d
and you can so that means that this
implies that you can choose d
to be order one over epsilon squared
okay
so
um
that's one proof um
what i want to do next time is to show
you another proof that there's a low
degree polynomial approximator
for a half space what's not nice about
this
proof is that it's not going to
generalize very easily
you know say instead of
instead of trying to approximate a half
space by a polynomial
you'd like to approximate you know a
convex set
by a polynomial the characteristic
function of a convex set
in high dimensions by a polynomial well
you could do well i guess it won't work
you can't project down to one dimension
now uh yeah no i wanted to say that you
could
try to do a inclusion exclusion
yeah that's horrible yeah so actually
you know what what we did after we found
this proof
was we went to you know all of the
approximation theorists that we knew
and we said hey you know we're able to
actually explicitly find a bound for a
single half space
we'd like to do more interesting
geometric sets
like and they said well kind of what
sets do you want to approximate
convex sets oh convex sets you know
hopeless uh you know if you're
interested in a cylinder
intersected with a hyperplane and a
pyramid
and a simplex in four dimensions like i
can probably do the integration for you
uh and that was disappointing because we
wanted to really
um come up with a low degree
approximator for arbitrary convex sets
or certainly at least the intersection
of two hyperplanes
um and although there's a beautiful
beautiful theory of approximation
it seems to be too kind of fine grain
to really use for these types of
problems i mean
you'll get very you can get very very
accurate bounds on the
approximation degree and that's what
these approximation theorists can do
they'll give you very very accurate
bounds
but we're willing to work with you know
very broad estimates on what these
bounds are
we don't need type you know the tightest
of bounds
and so we needed some other methodology
uh to try and bound the degree of the
polynomial that approximates these
characteristic functions
and um a quantity i mean noise stability
turns out to be sort of the right thing
to look at in fact surface area starts
to be
the right thing to look at and so next
time i'll talk about that
and then we'll move on to a result by
centos vimpala
on learning convex sets that
uses a very interesting interesting
result from
high dimensional convex geometry okay
thanks